behind me is the entrance to the
Greenwich foot tunnel in South London
it's your standard start of the 20th
century foot tunnel stairs are a lift
Down Under The River stairs are left
back up there's quite a few of these
left in the world but about 10 years
after this was built a German engineer
thought
what if we go bigger
this is the Saint Pauli elb tunnel in
Hamburg Germany much the same go in take
a lift down cross under the river except
it's not just pedestrians and bikes that
take the lift here this is good for cars
too
of course the automobile wasn't common
when this was built originally horses
and wagons would have been brought down
in these lifts and construction was
risky while it was being built the
tunnel was kept pressurized and
airlocked in order to keep the water out
but because decompression sickness the
bends wasn't understood hundreds of
workers suffered from what was then
called caisson's disease and three died
like the Greenwich tunnel this is a
useful commuter route for cars it's one
way in the morning and the other way in
the evening and there are speed bumps
just in case someone sees a clear tunnel
ahead of them undecides to I don't know
break the underground speed record most
road traffic goes elsewhere over other
routes under over the river but there
are still plenty of folks who regularly
use this odd 100 year old tunnel and car
lift as part of their everyday life
and yes for everyone who's inevitably
going to ask in the comments of course I
went to miniature Wonderland while I was
in Hamburg it's absolutely brilliant I
did the behind the scenes tour which is
well worth the money uh but there was
nothing I could film there with my
iPhone and GoPro that hasn't already
been shot by people with much much
better cameras so if you want to see
what's in there and it is incredible
I'll put some links in the description